[Music]
oh yeah here yeah no no don't do it
that's for reviewing foodfight hello I'm
the Nostalgia Critic guy remember it so
you don't have to we all know the
Halloween classics that we watch every
year from the old Universal Monsters
like Dracula and Frankenstein to the 80s
slasher like Freddy and Jason deep in
kids specials like Charlie Brown and The
Nightmare Before Christmas but the great
thing about Halloween is we keep trying
to push it further and further and sure
enough over the years some new classics
heavy ball the criteria for them isn't
super specific it doesn't have to be a
certain time frame very well known or
even necessarily a good product
beginning to end but they do have to be
drenched in something new something
unique something you can just look at
and think one word Halloween we're
counting down the all-time best new
Halloween classics and trust me when I
say the best one doesn't disappoint
we're here to make the top 11 obscure
Halloween films even less obscure why
top 11 because I like to go one step
beyond so sit back and enjoy the top 11
new Halloween classics
number one the Saw movies I'm not gonna
lie I'm not a fan of these films even
the first one I didn't like so much
there's a million things that didn't
make sense about if you want more detail
why go watch cinemasins
but that doesn't mean I don't see why
these movies became a staple of
Halloween the concept of each film is
there's a killer known as jigsaw and he
sets up death traps where if you wish to
get away with your life you have to do
something horrible like kill another
person cut off a body part or heck even
force a terrible American accent
technically speaking he's not really a
murderer why he sounds as American as
Tommy was so the idea of torture horror
certainly existed long before this film
but not only was this the one that made
a mainstream but it was also the one
that people put themselves in the
situation what would I do if I was there
but I go through the terrible deed or
what I rather let death take its toll
film was so popular that the demand for
sequels every Halloween was always met
for several years there wasn't a
Halloween that went by without a saw
film help they even worked it into their
advertising even if people thought the
movie was gonna suck they had a
tradition going and they always
associate it with the holiday even if it
was the number 850 billion as long as
the word saw was in front of it there
would always be an audience the jigsaw
puppet has also worked its way into the
lineup of classic Halloween villains
whenever you know that image you know
exactly who he is and what movie you
came from whether you get wrapped up in
the stories or not there's no doubt
about it that the Saw films have
certainly left their mark and chances
are it's one that won't be healing
anytime soon you have given me the news
that they're gonna die sell now you
we'll be the gloss of death
Liberto Halloween 3 the season of the
winch many hated this film when it first
came out and I'm not gonna lie I did -
not only does it have nothing to do with
the first two Halloween movies which was
later reviewed that the producers wanted
each movie to be a different story but
if that was the case how come the first
two continue the same story hello
but the film itself just seemed
downright silly you go from a story
about a slasher to a film about witches
kind of that use technology kind of that
uses spells kind of to kill kids because
kind of no real reason yeah it's a
pretty nonsensical setup even if you
want to accept it as its own film but as
time went by I did find myself thinking
back to it a lot I do remember the
characters I do remember the visuals and
who the hell could ever forget that
goddamn song hey morning why stop trying
to take it so seriously I found it
actually had its own strange unique
charm to it it surrounded an 80's decor
has all sorts of broody atmosphere and
by god there's just Halloween stuff
everywhere I mean everywhere in a way I
actually associate this movie more with
Halloween than I do the first Halloween
simply because Halloween is all over the
place it's nowhere near as good as the
first film in fact I think you could
debate whether or not it's even a good
film at all but it's look for the
holiday from the classic costumes today
candy - watching specials as a family
and some fucked up supernatural thing
going on while watching it as a family
it cries a heaven to you much but I have
a past it actually does kind of get you
in the mood for the season maybe that's
why it was called season of the witch
because it's not meant to deliver a
story about the holiday
rather an essence of the holiday and
there's no doubt you can feel that
essence of the season all throughout the
film whatever your thoughts you know you
get sucked into the witching hour
whenever it's played on TV what else can
you say but still very shamrock am I not
[Music]
the Paranormal Activity movies again
splitting a lot of audiences down the
middle the Paranormal Activity movie
still managed to produce major creeps
with little cost
well many see the Blair Witch Project as
the film that made the found footage
genre popular it was definitely
Paranormal Activity that kept it going
the film about a couple whose house
seems to be possessed by an evil entity
started out in very few theaters but
word of mouth spread so fast that they
actually worked into their advertising
that people asked the movie theater
owners for it yeah isn't that weird a
commercial for a movie that's actually
asking you to demand the movie in your
movie theater
can you remember another film commercial
that's done that having never really
been asked that by our TVs before or
audiences shrugged and said why not they
demanded to see the film in their
theaters and sure enough it became a
smash resulting its sequel after sequel
coming out and just like saw it came out
every year during Halloween but unlike
saw these films were much easier and
faster to make because it relied on
fewer production costs
it looked like amateur filmmaking that
was fine because it was supposed to look
like amateur filmmaking it made it more
realistic and his point of view action
made many audience members feel like
they were right there experiencing the
scares as the characters were witnessing
it no are they all good even the most
die-hard fan would probably say no me
personally I think - it's the only one
that was actually great from beginning
to
but even that's worse every movie had
something new and innovative to offer
the first one had scary subtlety the
second one had brilliant editing the
third one has a slow reveal of the
moving camera the fourth one had the
clever use of the household appliances
and the fifth one yeah the acting was
nice it's understandable if not everyone
gets scared by these movies but the new
ways each film delivers a new kind of
scare is really something to admire even
if you do got to sit through a lot of
repeated cliches to get to them always
keeping the dread hides the Paranormal
Activity films knew how to scare an
awful lot with an awful loop number
eight cabin in the woods I've never seen
a film that had such a devoted fanbase
of people who have dedicated themselves
to not spoiling of a movie it's amazing
any time you talk to someone they always
say I can't tell you anything about it
you just have to see it and in honor of
that I won't spoil it for you either
though I do have to talk a little bit
about it but still we'll keep this
mostly spoiler free the dress wiener it
in Oroville relies much on surprise and
twist so like I said I won't give too
much away what I can say is on the
surface it looks like any other scary
film a bunch of college kids go to a
cabin in the middle of nowhere and of
course some supernatural evil tries to
destroy them it sounds basic enough but
as the film progresses you find out very
quickly that this is a love letter to
not one but every kind of horror movie
ever made and in a way you probably
never would have expected it tries
everything to incorporate all the
classic tropes through scares humor and
damn clever writing and honestly to say
anymore with ruin the fun and I think
that's why so many people consider it
such a unique scary movie it's a film
you enjoy having revealed to you and you
get excited the more and more you start
to figure it out when you do figure out
what it's up to
you realize you're having such fun with
the cons
and realize that not only is it paying
homage to so many scary genres but it's
practically creating its own I don't
know I can't think of any other movies
that have done specifically what this
film is done at least while still
remaining a horror the discovery is too
delicious to ruin and I won't be the one
to do it so let's just say it's a ton of
fun of you know the secret but even more
fun if you don't it works as both a
great trick and treat on Halloween night
no matter what happens we have to stay
together this is Russia should split up
yeah good idea
really number seven
oculus yep this film is not even a year
old but already it has the makings of a
classic from its advertising it looks
like any modern-day horror film but when
you start to watch it you realize how
diabolically genius it is a young man is
released out of a mental institution
where he is greeted by his sister he was
under the thought that a haunted mirror
was responsible for the death of his
parents it was thus put away for it just
as he's released and he thinks he's
gotten better he discovers that the
sister has found the mirror and wishes
to prove to the world that it is indeed
haunted murdering several people in the
past including their folks what follows
is an exercise and insanity trying to
figure out what's real and what's not
the idea of a haunted mirror is clever
enough but all throughout the movie we
have no idea if this thing is really
possessed or if it's just our two heroes
going crazy the mirror apparently plays
with your mental state making you see
one thing when something else is going
on the reason this is so ingenious is
that the brother has spent years having
it drilled in his head that it's not and
the sister has spent years totally
convinced that it is and is literally
devoting her life to proving it both
battle back and forth as we descended to
the madness of the past present and even
future of what's to
we're seeing the story literally as
they're remembering it if they're even
remembering it correctly and they're
constantly getting visions of what could
happen to them or maybe what will happen
to them but again they had no idea the
cursed mirror is real or if it's
literally then sharing the exact same
madness either way they're both going
crazier and crazier trying to figure it
out as such we don't know either what's
going on and are terrified to see if
they'll make it out of this alive or
continue to torture themselves both
physically and mentally maybe to the
death you two have a hard time trying to
figure out what's real or even where you
are half the time the line is so blurred
that you share in the insanity and the
paranoia of what's going on constantly
having to second-guess everything and
keeping the suspense high even if you
don't find it scary
it's a great psychological dive into the
torture my two siblings who don't know
what's real anymore transitioning the
battle from the internal to the external
great imagery wonderful acting and one
hell of a great concept
oculus may be recent but I get the
feeling it's staying ability is going to
last for a long time
[Music]
number six murder party you probably
never heard of this one but trust me
when I say it's worth the search a
low-budget horror comedy the film takes
place on Halloween as a lonely nobody is
given an invitation to a murder party he
has no idea what it is so he decides to
get in the costume and go ahead anyway
without giving too much away
he's led to a location of the most
insecure and pretentiously psychotic
people you'll ever meet in your life and
the rest of the film is just him trying
to figure out a way to use their own
stupidity as a means to escape the whole
film worked as a messed up version of
the emperor's new clothes trying to use
the second judgment of what's popular
what's not to try and gain superiority
but as the film goes on you have no idea
what each character's definition of
superiority is or how far they're
willing to go to get it one by one we
see a new level of idiocy revealed and
we like our main character try to figure
out what degree these people are
dangerous thus he has to use his
understanding of each person's moronic
wave to figure out how to best them even
though he himself is not particularly
smart think a conversation at the Mad
Hatter's Tea Party except instead of
being seated in the chair you're tied to
it and every action you make will either
result in you living or die you're both
on the edge of your seat and laughing
your ass off as you watch the totally
insane people try to act like they're
one step ahead of the curve
I am creativity Gore and of course
shitload of laughs murder party is an
invitation you want to resist but can
help by eagerly attend
[Music]
number five
Coraline it's funny what Tim Burton
started with The Nightmare Before
Christmas it seems every stop-motion
will be released though few there are is
trying to recreate that dark yet child
centered cult following that turned at
the big box with Jack Skellington but
instead of turning into something that's
boring and tired every single film has
demonstrated something that's creative
and new and Coraline is no exception
directed by the same person who did
Nightmare Before Christmas Coraline
focuses on a girl who wishes she had a
more interesting life she finds a small
door where on the other end seems to be
exactly that she has a new mother and
father that seemed just like the old
ones except they seemed nicer and better
but as she continues to visit this world
it only gets more and more psychotic and
soon it becomes an attempt to escape
from the clutches of an evil demon it's
pretty much as batshit insane as it
sounds one of the joys of this family
film is that there really is no perfect
character everyone is at least a little
bit selfish even Coraline can be kind of
mean-spirited but at the same time it's
made clear when they realize they've
gone too far and when they realize who
are the real monsters and who are the
ones they love this is one of the few
movies that actually warrants the PG
rating but I mean that in a good way
it's not just a G film with a swear word
or a sneaky sex innuendo in there it's
definitely some extreme imagery with
some extreme scary ideas especially for
kids but at the same time it still has
the charm and timeless characters to
make it continually watchable characters
that kids can easily relate to and enjoy
viewing at a time of the year when kids
like to be scared this is one to get
them creeped out without having to go
too gory in fact it's not gory at all
it's just scary imagery the whole film
is filled with rich environments
creative landscapes and strange
creatures the cold colors are perfect
for being welcoming one moment and
terrifying the next just what any little
kid is looking for on Halloween Timah
dating and intense but always coming
back to the spirit of home Coraline
knows how to create a fantasy world
the darkened
[Music]
number four Hotel Transylvania as much
as we all love to dump on Adam Sandler
movies I can clearly say this is one of
his best films in years energized
spontaneous romantic and downright
hilarious this is one of the most
realized renditions of what seems like a
OneNote idea Count Dracula has opened a
hotel where all the classic monsters can
be safe from the pitchforks of humanity
but his only daughter is restless
because she wants to leave and see the
world
overprotective of his child Dracula is
horrified to find a human about her age
accidentally stumbles across the hotel
and quickly falls in love with her the
rest of the film is trying to keep the
human boy's identity a secret while also
trying to keep peace in his humble abode
there's too many good things to count in
this movie the characters are all
memorable and funny each with a unique
identity and mostly as an L alumni to
voice them the story balances out fast
and timeless jokes with surprisingly
dramatic and heartfelt moments as well
the animation amazing this is some of
the quickest and most energized movement
I've ever seen on screen every action is
filled with sharp and distinct motion
every character has a distinct walk
every character has distinct movement
but again it never goes too far to
interrupt the slower emotional moments
Sandler as Dracula sounds like a
horrible choice but again he brings a
real heart and passion to it making him
completely irresistible look at that
smile how can you not light up whenever
he makes that face what should have been
a non motivating idea takes advantage of
every joke at every opportunity that can
be done with it turning out to be one of
the most hyperactive animated movies
ever it's just always on it's just
always moving it never lets up except
for the moments where the characters
turmoil needs to shine through and
that's done pretty good as well
it's ambition is only matched by the
dedication of its crew and this crew
went above and beyond what it needed to
do if you want to laugh at the things
that go bump in the night this is
perfect place to stay and witness it let
it come down Pennsylvania
[Music]
number three Shaun of the Dead we all
know about the classic zombie films like
Night of the Living Dead Dawn of the
Dead etc but this is one of the few
films that not only satirize the zombie
films but somehow still stays faithful
to them the British comedy stars a lazy
absent-minded Simon Pegg with its even
lazier roommate played by Nick Frost
when the zombie apocalypse happens
however they turned into unlikely heroes
trying to fight off baddies while also
trying to get laid and drunk at the same
time people are so familiar with this
movie it's hard to know what to say
about it lots of hidden jokes in both
the foreground and background are
constantly flying by the characters
selfishness and idiocy constantly makes
for lots of laughs that are silly but
still kind of identifiable which music
album would you hold on to during end
times
Pogo write our songs it'll definitely
know the famine Center but what really
makes it stand out is that it still
works as a traditional zombie film
there's still a lot of suspense there's
still a lot of dread and grief there's
tons of social satire they even have the
painful moments where tough sacrifices
have to be made incorporating a lot of
the traditional character tropes like
the pessimist the optimist the kind soul
the mean old bat and of course the
brainless losers this makes for a very
strange but enjoyable combo of comedy
and scares still showing their love and
dedication to the zombie genre but also
poking fun of a at the same time what
else do I even need to say about if you
see it a million times you'll see it a
million more it's dead on arrival but in
a good
number two ParaNorman as a follow-up to
Coraline many people thought this would
just be a retread of what's already been
done before with the creepy kid centered
stop-motion film but those who saw it
know not only was this film different
from Coraline but it surpassed it Norman
is a little boy who has the ability to
see dead people
yeah again sounds like we'll be
retreading quite a bit here but what
makes it interesting is that a witch's
spell has brought back the dead as
zombies and Norman has to find a way to
get them back to rest beyond that much
like cabin in the woods I can't say too
much a lot of it plays with expectation
of character types but it takes it in a
totally different direction the cabin in
the woods did the film never goes
straight up satire it still keeps the
focus on the emotion and turmoil of our
characters that seems to get stronger
and stronger the more you see what's
revealed we realize it's not the ghouls
that are haunting many of our characters
but rather the decisions of the past as
you learn more and more there's a
surprisingly powerful story about
acceptance versus vengeance you find
yourself not only getting invested in it
but healing for every single person
who's involved that's pretty rare not
only for a Halloween film before a
family Halloween the line for how to
feel about these characters is so
blurred that you don't know whether
you're supposed to fear them or hug them
it could have been so easy just to make
this a good versus evil story like a lot
of Halloween films but then we wouldn't
be so involved in the tragedy of the
story and become so emotionally engaged
ParaNorman might surprise you and how
sophisticated it can be with its overall
fee it has lighter moments sure but
doesn't shy away from some very tough
and heavy elements it certainly gave
much more than I thought it was going to
and for those who love it and have
watched it over and over
we know it's had quite an impact on us
it's that love and commitment and not
just the idea behind the creepy
characters but the feelings behind them
as well that's what makes a great
monster movie a great monster it's
finding that the scariest part about the
scariest creatures is that they are
human
any of us can become these things at any
time but ParaNorman does it in a way
that's a little bit different again I
can't go into too much detail but it's
gripping it's interesting and even kind
of touching its third act is radically
different than what you probably would
have predicted it would be
but again that's part of why it's so
great it's constantly surprising and
constantly delighted awesome visuals a
creative story and memorable characters
that's more than enough for a downright
fantastic new Halloween classic
[Music]
and the number one raped fucking bad-ass
awesome new Halloween classic is you
know what should have runners up I don't
usually do it but I like the subject I
think it deserves it this time the ring
okay it doesn't hold up the best over
time but that creepy ending and that
image of that girl in every single
Halloween store it's definitely worth
mentioning Halloween that almost wasn't
pretty silly an awkward but performances
from these hilarious actors totally
makes it worth it Halloween tree a lot
of people wanted me to review this I
don't get why it's creative it's
educational it's Ray Bradbury what's not
to like maggoty in and the pumpkin that
couldn't smile yeah sounds lame and it
is kind of slow but its atmosphere is so
laid-back and drenched in Halloween it's
hard not to like the original haunting
pretty well known so I didn't included
but a timeless classic all the same
trick-or-treat kind of a hitman is but
it might be the first film where the
trick or treater is actually one of the
villains that alone is worth an
honorable mention Exorcist Lee
practically an apology for Exorcist 2
with much better story and scares
Zombieland a great comedy with great
last I think sure the dead just did it a
little better now on to number one and I
mean it what I say how awesome it is
it's nostalgic it's funny it's soaked in
classic Halloween let's get right to it
all-time number one new Halloween
classic is you know what this film is so
awesome and so cool it deserves its own
review yeah so that's what I'm gonna do
tune in next week guys is I'm gonna
dedicate an entire review to this 80s
bomb that turned out to be a fantastic
awesome kick-ass Halloween classic I'm
the Nostalgia Critic and I can't fucking
wait
but I prize him build it up that much
connection it's fucking awesome
[Music]
you